[Musique]
moi c'est simple nous sommes en salies
et joue le rôle de ma star moi c'est
bosch et geôles route de caen match je
m'appelle rachid super moi je m'appelle
intime
dans série 0 ou série comme moi
c'est extraordinaire du jour au
lendemain on se retrouve comme ça avec
des millions des tonnes de vue c'est
c'est sublime bah on va bien sûr les
deux mais je
[Rires]
[Musique]
moi j'ai validé par ce que il ya plein
de théorie donc en fait ça m'a un peu le
doute
ouais validant ils sont bien pris la
tête moi je voulais pas du tout pris la
tête merci mon agent libre pas du tout
mais bon c'est vrai et on détaille les
voiliers du d'un crime et c'est ça qui
est bien à partir du moment où il ya des
dingueries d'accord c'est que c'est
positif quand les gens je te reste à
celle excuses critique ce match parce
que c'est bon du coup tu valides la
vallée d'alassay manger que j'ai compris
la venue à venir
[Musique]
moi je balise mais chose que je valide
moi mais ça fait partie du personnage de
quoi il parle plus ça va moi je valide
le fait d'avoir bien évolué que y
amarrer rico et et pris leur envol un
petit peu et ont pu faire leur bout de
chemin dans la musique n'en valaient pas
leur manière de procéder du tout non
dans la série où il va litres milan ac
mais parce que c'est lourd ça pourrait
nous apporter sa part des trucs et ou
dans la vraie vie dont elle rêvait des
mecs comme ça on ne l'est pas et je
pense pas qu'il nouvelle et non plus
toutes les rappeuses qui sont en train
d'émerger au prix ont déjà émergé qui
ont déjà des noms et bien sûr des rois
des talents de mode et rapport c'est
très très bien qui est de tout amour il
ya beaucoup d'amour beaucoup ta lamarre
a obligé de valider valait bien sûr
qu'on allait bien fait on voit les deux
faux
j'ai beaucoup aimé la fin de la saison 1
mais là ce qui est bien ce qu'ils ont
pris note d'une direction deux
n'ont pas validé